[Musique]
commandant damien ernest au nom du
président la république je vous fait
chevalier de la légion d'honneur
capitaine anthony lancelot au nom du
président de la république nous fait
chevalier de la légion d'honneur
secrétaire administratif brice le mescam
au nom du président la république je
vous fait chevalier de la légion
d'honneur
capitaine aurélia triple heroes au nom
du président de la république
chevalier de la légion d'honneur
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs 7 minutes 7
minutes ont suffit à plonger la
préfecture de police de paris dans un
des drames les plus douloureux de son
histoire et la france dans la stupeur et
l'incompréhension sept minutes
sept minutes ont suffi pour arracher la
vie à quatre des vôtres et le tribut
aurait été plus lourd encore si un
gardien de la paix stagiaire ayant
rejoint le métier depuis seulement six
jours petits jours n'avait fait preuve
d'une maîtrise et d'un courage hors
norme
en neutralisant l'assaillant après les
sommations requise beaucoup a été fait
durant toutes ces dernières années pour
mieux repérer la menace améliorer les
informations mieux identifier suivre les
individus les traquer partout en prison
dans nos services publics dans les
entreprises fermer des écoles dissoudre
des associations loi après loi budget
après budget nous ne cesserons jamais de
resserrer chaque instant un peu plus les
mailles du filet ce n'est en aucun cas
un combat contre une religion mais bien
contre son dévoiement et ce qui conduit
au terrorisme opposons à la haine
l'intransigeance républicaine à la
terreur l'irréductible esprit français
de résistance à l'obscurantisme l'amour
de la raison et son exigence faisons
bloc tous
ici réunis nation toute entière
nous le faisons pour nos enfants nous le
faisons au nom de la nation
vive la république vive la france
[Musique]